welcome back to the edge live in your
bleaching Report app it was a crazy day
in the NFL so let's get right into it
you're with your boy Micha Parsons let's
get straight into it always big game big
game big one big win another dominant
performance Cowboys Giants it's what we
love to see uh like I said we always
love to get back on the winning train uh
big we got a chance to have another big
one to go back to back uh against the
Panthers next week but you know we'll
get into that later biggest takeaway
um I told y'all Dak for MVP Dak has been
playing at extremely high level since
the 49ers game yes the 49ers game he
wasn't his best uh whatever whatever Bad
Games happens but from then on Dak has
been on a man a man on a mission it has
been great to see I love to see it he is
playing at extremely high level 20 26
for 35 404 yards five total touchdowns
and three quarters currently number
three in qbr this season he is playing
lights out that's my QB QB W for sure
without a doubt about it and then my dog
88 88 for a
reason number 88 CD lamb 11 reception
151 yards one touchdown it's actually
funny cuz I went up to CD and I was like
well you know uh AJ Brown he had six
games straight over uh
125 and uh after he had about 140 in the
game he said ever see somebody go for
150 three games in a row I said nope I
haven't and he answered the call the
first player in NFL history with three
straight games with 10 plus receptions
and 150 plus reception yards he is
without a doubt a number one receiver he
is a top three receiver in the
league and there there's no arguments
about it and if I get my top three right
now who's playing at Elite level right
now has to be Tyreek Hill AJ Brown and
CD lamb I don't even think it's a it's a
discussion he is the number one there
was questions is going into the season
can cidd be a number one can he do this
can he do that and he answered the call
cidd is a number one receiver he is one
of the best if not the best receiver in
the league right now in a three-week
span I he he's breaking numbers box
office whatever you want to put it CD is
that guy and we need to start putting
respect on his name um he did 190
against the Eagles 150 plus and then
it's just something we're starting he's
almost averaging 100 yards a game at
this point in uh the season so another
big game out of him and you see what
he's doing so man uh CD and then I I
seen a lot of reactions a lot of fans
want to know my thoughts about you know
what I was tweeting and about me playing
offb linebacker listen Nobody's Perfect
all teams aren't perfect um like I said
it was scheme they decided they wanted
me off ball I just show up and you know
play you know at the end day I I have no
control over what's called or what I'm
doing I just I just gota have faith in
the coaches and what's going on and
things like that so um there there
there's nothing more I can put on that
um but let's just get right into
football Cowboys over big win let's get
it cowboys how about them Cowboys but a
wild Sunday fans are talking about the
AFC North race let's bring that up both
Bengals and bills are currently out of
the playoff pitcher it is there
something to worry
about and honestly there isn't really
nothing to worry about when it comes to
the Bengals yes they they just don't
have Grace because they had a rough
start with Joe B's injury and things
like that but I don't think there's
nothing truly to worry about and then
it's starting to say are the Texans
going to make this jump and be uh are
the Texans going to make the playoffs
and I think they have a chance they have
a chance with CJ stri at quarterback but
I have no I think the finals I think the
AFC is extremely tough you know when you
look at these teams and what they're
doing and what CJ Stone he went down to
HUD nation and just did what he did you
know another comeback you know gutsy win
I mean it it's tough to say but I do
think the Browns I mean the Bengals Will
Make A Way um the Bengals will make a
way I don't know about the bills they
have to start playing a lot better
football they haven't been playing the
elite level of playoff football we've
been saying but the bang but the Bengals
have so that's something we would like
to see I think the Bengals will make it
I think the Texans will make it and
obviously you know the Browns will make
it um what does the comeback win for the
Browns say about them what I've been
telling you people the Browns are the
real deal they are an elite playoff team
I wouldn't be surprised by playoff time
if they're number two or number three
seed they are playing great football and
they doing this with injuries Deshawn
Watson is finding ways to win yes he
makes mistakes yes he's getting back in
the football but he is showing a way
he's finding a way that defense is
serious Greg Newsome a huge pick to send
that game to where it did and Sean
Watson the kicker did the rest but you
have to realize this defense is the real
thing they just beat if not the best
team in foot NFL football right now that
was the Baltimore Ravens and they had a
win they came back what a lot of people
thought they couldn't do listen people
the Browns are going to surprise a lot
of people this year I know everyone has
High host for these teams but they are
the real deal do not sleep on them no
more they are coming for heads they're
turning heads and I've been looking to
always way since the very beginning cuz
I seen it coming fans are questioning
about the Steelers what are the reason
they are six and three well let me tell
you reason what I've been telling you
people and what it will forever willever
happen for years and for however
football will continue to go along
defense wins championships when you have
TJ wat Alex High Smith and you have this
backend Joey Porter who's playing Elite
level might win Defensive Rookie of the
Year he should win Defensive Rookie of
the Year and if Jaylen Carter doesn't
take over cuz Jaylen cars playing at
Elite level but you guys have to realize
that defense will always Prevail no
matter how good your quarterback is no
matter how good your running back is or
how good your receiver is if they cannot
move the ball if they cannot put up
words you have a great chance at winning
football defense will always win
championships no and that's the history
of football without a defense you cannot
win it doesn't matter for it's a
shootout you must get stops and the
Steelers find ways to get stops and they
score on defense def so it does not
matter defense will win championships
that's why the Steelers are uh six and
three they find a way on defense they
are hold they have a top defense and
that's what it's about and you say who
is the best team in the AFC North can we
pull up the AFC North again please the
best team in the and it's tough because
these is all great teams I think this is
if not the best division if not one of
the best divisions in football but right
now it it still has to be the Ravens but
I if if I were to put it in order it has
to go Baltimore Cleveland uh Bengals and
Pittsburgh just because you really do
want to see a little bit more out of
Pittsburgh's offense you do want to see
Penny Kenny picket play better but if if
that defense doesn't come on that day if
that defense doesn't show up can they
still win games with Kenny picket can
Kenny picket go win them the game that's
the only reason why they're not ranked
higher do you have belief that Kenny
picket can win that game but other than
that this is a this is the best division
of football right now without a doubt
and it and and it sucks cuz they're all
in the same division so this is
something you love to see uh that's my
order the Baltimore Ravens is still at
the number one right now um they're
still explosive still have one of the
best defenses um but like I said you
just can't turn the ball over and
Cleveland had the big stops and made a
way found a way another big matchup was
49ers
Jaguars um what does this game say about
the 49ers or the Jaguars well first I
want to say with the the 49ers doing
what they doing right the 49ers are
fully healthy they are a scary team
having Debo the creativity of Kyle
Shanahan has been truly something
amazing to see I was watching the game
and I said they just ran a post trp fake
Jet Sweep with Trent Williams when you
have Trent Williams back in the lineup
you can do so many more amazing things
he they find a way to utilize his
strength they find a way to use utilize
Debo um and and we had some questions
and and I was always a big supporter of
the Jaguars and I still am but they
showed up they found a way to dominate
the Jaguars on both sides of the ball
where I thought the Jaguars might have
played better defensively played with a
little bit more effort I thought the
Jaguars offensively struggled a lot only
putting up three points but that can
bring up the point that the the 49ers
have the one of the best D lines in
football Chase young had his debut he
had a half sacks 2B QB hits Nick Bosa a
sack and a half Javon hardgrave a second
and half that D line is scary and then
Fred Warner with an interception uh
picks I mean we have to be real folks
the 49ers were fully healthy they are a
scary unit um I don't I think the
Jaguars can play better I don't think
the Jaguars play their brand of football
without a doubt I do think so I'm not
going to punish the Jaguars for that
loss but it does show you with the 49s
are capable of they dominate teams when
are fully healthy and when they're out
there on the field so um it it just
shows you the 49ers is I know they're
happy to get back on the winom and they
dominate a good team like the
Jacksonville Jaguars which is
important another NFC team that's been
making a lot of noise is the Detroit
Lions jir Gibbs and David Montgomery
went
off and where do they rank amongst RB
Duos in the league um I would they're
easily top three um if not top two uh
without a question um and and and
they're dominating uh and when you have
two running backs over 100 plus yards it
it's easy it's it's very easy it's not
even a question um they top three but
that goes up to the old lineman the Run
game everything they're doing um what
their coaches doing you know the
creativity to get these guys going and
things like that the Lions have been a
real deal quite some time they continue
to dominate football and win games on
this run game uh they're living dying
and buying by and Jared G's making the
throw
so it It's always important to see um
after this gritty win where do you rate
the lions in the NFC um and they and
they won six of their last seven games I
I would have to rank the Lions a top
five team in the NFC um without a
without a question um depending how you
want to argue how you want to look at it
uh strength of schedule who they played
they beat some great teams they beat the
Kansas City Chiefs um and teams like
that so the lions are easily a top five
team and that's just there's just no
question about an NFC they're going to
make a running playoffs um they're going
to be a top you know four seed and you
know I think they're going to win their
division they're going to win that NFC
North division so the Lions is a team
that we see later next month and you
know it's a team that we got to worry
about and I only think they're going to
have a handful of uh losses so uh and
that's just the truth about it on the
other side Sunday was the charge of 13th
loss by three or fewer points since the
team drafted Justin Herbert that's the
most such losses in the NFL over that
span what are the Chargers missing I
think the Chargers aren't really missing
anything I think they have the front um
they have a pretty good old line um and
they have a lot of great weapons it it
just comes down to uh discipline
accountability and find a way to Edge
out find a way to Edge out these teams I
think that's the difference between uh
good and great teams the Chargers are a
really good team but they're just not
great yet great teams like the eagles
the 49ers they find find ways to win um
even the Browns they found a way to win
uh by that small margin they find a way
to overcome adversity um when our Verity
hits they got to find a way to overcome
and and that's just the truth about it
you have all the pieces it just come
down to the players and coaches they got
to find a way to find a way to uh win in
that margin and that's just the reality
of it um so I don't think I think
they're a really good team though they
have the quarterback they have Kenan
Allen they have Eckler and they have
Derwin James they have c m Joey Bosa uh
Morgan Fox they have great players
Kenneth Murray on their team they just
have to find a way to win the close
games because that's what the great
teams
do uh another player that has been
dominating uh in and out this year he's
on another roster and that's Josh dos I
talked about Josh dos with Gilly on
Friday and he went off against his first
start but then he comes out and does it
again 23 for 34 26 yards two total
touchdown I mean the man didn't even
know where the locker room was let's be
real folks I think this is this might be
our comeback player of the year and it
should be um the and I think people have
to realize the adversity and the things
he overcame to be at this point you know
left Cleveland you know left Cleveland
ended up in Arizona um now he's in the
Vikings and wins two games you know um
and it's looking scared and he did this
without Justin Jefferson they still
don't have Justin Jefferson um he's
finding ways to get everybody involved
in the game I think that's the hardest
part about
um that is the hardest part about
battling a new quarterback because you
don't know his reads you don't know who
he likes to go to yet and you know and
he's taking advantage of that um and
look what Justin Jefferson I cannot wait
to get back on the field with this team
again he doesn't have Justin Jefferson
we have to realize DOD dobs is playing
at extremely high level I mean and then
when you add Justin Jefferson we already
know what he's capable of he's a gritty
man he does it all and you know he's a
top five receiver in this league so I
mean like let's be real Josh dobs can
lead these guys to a playoff SP they're
currently ranked seventh if Josh dobs
leads the Vikings to the playoffs and
holds that down even win a playoff what
does that mean for him does he get an
opportunity to start for a team does he
get his opportunity to be that guy
because he hasn't gotten that
opportunity yet he hasn't got his full
opportunity he's been bounced around a
lot in this league but he's making it
happen he's seen every look he's played
in so many different systems can he get
the opportunity to be a number one um
and I would love to see that for him
he's he's overcoming everything can he
get his opportunity cuz he hasn't gotten
it yet another big team uh but this is
more AFC is the Raiders the Raiders are
two- 0 under Antonio Pierce um my first
initial reaction was you know obviously
with McDaniels getting fired and you
know they're starting off so bad you're
like are are they tanking are they going
to go get uh Caleb Williams in the draft
are what what are they planning but they
said hold up wait a minute I'm not
finished and they're going 2 and0
they're smoking cigars in the locker
room their the Energy's higher they're
dancing this is what a fun winning
locker room environment should look like
I'm glad my guy Devonte Adams is finally
happy um this is what it should be like
um like people to fail to realize like
coaching matters it it's not so much of
the players it's about the coaches how
do you treat the players how do the
players treat each other in the locker
room and this is what you love to see I
think the Raiders I don't know it might
be too late it might not we'll see how
they finish the year but the Raiders is
a good team they have a lot of good
players can they put it all together
though can they keep putting it all
together um and and it's and extremely
important because if they do and they do
end up with a top 10 pick they get a guy
to add to this beautiful roster that
they have and they make a run next year
and do they give Antonio Pierce a
deserving chance I would love to see him
finish the year strong and let him get
an opportunity to keep uh keep uh
coaching this team because they
obviously love them players are talking
about that run through the wall for him
and and that's the environment you have
cuz that's the type of environment we
have in the Dallas Cowboys we have that
run through the wall for our coaches uh
loving and you know beautiful
relationship between everyone in the
building but on the flip side you know
you're seeing this in college you're
seeing this in the NFL coaches are
getting these big 10 million5 million $6
million contracts fully guaranteed and
and you starting to see this trend that
coaches getting fired like Jimbo fish
still owed 70 million and he won't be
there no more like that is outrageous
you you can't even imagine a player that
has put more effort put more pain put
more suffering into uh players and
they're not they're not seeing anything
from it they get released they get let
go and they're not owed anything and
they put way more into uh the team
everything they have than these coaches
do you know sometimes you see a coach
last one year two years but you see uh
players like Zeke or players like uh all
across the league Chandler Jones or
however may be they put five seven years
of hard earned years into these programs
and they just get let go with nothing to
nothing to gain from it so you know you
start to see this trend and it's not
just these players it's a bunch of
players that might get let go if they're
not still putting up the same numbers or
what whatever it may be um and they just
let these guys go but these coaches are
still getting so much money I'm not
taking away coaches there's great
coaches that deserve it and and uh so
forth but I I think there needs to be a
little bit more balance a little bit
more fairness into this equation cuz and
that's just reality we're giving these
coaches millions and and and it starts
to make you think why aren't they
charged against the cap you know um
they're not charged against the cap but
uh all these players are I get it but at
the end of the day let players get more
guaranteed let players get fully
guaranteed contracts let's guarantee
their future as you same do these
coaches especially your High Caliber
players you know I think guys like Lamar
Jackson there's deserve a fully
guaranteed deal whether um whether he
gets injured or not or he's not
sustaining what the type of play level
he's at but at the end of the day you
guys have to realize Lamar is selling
jersey selling tickets you're going
there to see Lamar you're not going to
see the owners you're not going there to
see the coach and that's just the
reality he's bringing more value to the
organization than these coaches are so
uh and and that's just the reality
Raiders are playing somewhere between 40
and 80 million to Josh mcel and John
guden to not coach that's two coaches
making close to $80 million you're not
coaching you know and is that fair I
believe not but in a reality this is the
world we live in this is the sport we
play I'm extremely grateful extremely
blessed to be in these opportunities but
it it's just not fair the the equality
within the players is just not there and
you see it time and time
again uh there was actually a funny
moment over the weekend and we're going
to move past this where it was
Michigan's interm coach and I tweeted
about this um and it was his interview
uh shiron Moore after the
game uh to say that this has been a
crazy 24 hours for your guys to win on
the road in this environment when there
were doubts sh what does it mean to
you want to thank the Lord want to thank
Coach Harbaugh love you
man love the out of you man this
for you but this University the
president
all ad we got the best players best
university best alumni in the country
love you guys these guys right
here these guys right here man these
guys did it these guys did it man talk
to him man love
you I mean my thoughts are right I
thought it was a little funny um but you
know that that's the that's the love and
passion we love to see for the game you
could tell this guy truly cares about uh
the kids he worked for you tell you
could tell he cares about the university
uh he's grateful for his opportunity and
it's not often uh you know young men
like him get an opportunity to coach so
you know he's he's getting and he went
to a hostile environment he went there
and beat my NY lions and and that's hard
to do and you
know we just althar was dragged because
it it almost seemed like you know
Harbaugh had passed away or something
like that if you ain't known better you
just saw that interview um you know you
you would think something was what
happened to John Harbo I think that's
why a lot of people's uh reactions was
that um but you know I thought it was a
great interview um I don't think there's
nothing wrong with anything that he said
um I just thought you know a lot of
people might have thought it was a
little dramatic but you love to see that
passion you love to see everything he's
bringing to the game um what are my
thoughts about Sidelines uh hard ball
suspension I mean I honestly hate that
type of suspension uh I think you should
just find a school or something like
that uh to take away a head coach
someone that they love playing for
someone they that they love having
around um taking him on the sidelines so
he can't can't coach him that's that's
tough and then say he can only coach
during the week I mean there's a lot
goes into that you know I think a lot of
players look to to their coaches in
times and um when it comes to time
management game management situations um
where Hardball does the best uh so I I
hate that type of suspension um and he
said they should Michigan should be
America's team now that's something I
disagree with America's team should
always be pen state after all the
adversity and things that Penn State
been through we should be America's team
um I don't agree with that Michigan has
always you know they they can never be
America's team especially after Ohio
State's dominance over the last you know
DEC or so guess they have been winning
the last two years um but we cannot just
start America's team like that thoughts
on all the Michigan players um you know
I and you know it's tough for the
Michigan players you see their reaction
they're all tweeting bet they're they're
feeling emotional even Tom Brady joined
in obviously it's more it's always more
than
just you know the player is is that
player coach relationship is so
important and and you just hate to see
that you know I and I just don't agree
and you know it it's wrong and last but
not least I want to get and well second
to not least I want to get into my man
CJ throut stra I told y'all last week he
was coming for heads he was coming for
nexts and you still continue to see it
CJ stra is dominating the NFL he is
making it look so easy like he is 4-1
against teams with a winning record he
has beat the Jacksonville Jack Wars he's
beat the Steelers he just
beat the Bengals teams that you would
think is so dominant so dominant like I
think like we are we cannot confuse this
CJ stra is a top 10 quarterback in the
NFL right now he is he should be in a
conversation for MVP he might just win
it all be the second player ever to win
offensive rookie and uh MVP in the same
season he's playing that Elite level he
has guys like Noah Brown Noah was a
great player for us and he's balling in
Houston Noah Brown second game over 100
yards in a row uh tank D's playing at a
really Elite level dalon schz is playing
at a really Elite level he is making the
players around him so much better CJ
Stout is he cemented himself it's not
even a like it shouldn't even be a
conversation he is an MVP caliber right
now he is playing the best football and
he's doing with less he's playing at a
Patrick Mahomes level if not right below
people do not realize that that he is
making a statement right now um and and
I seen a lot of conversation with people
bashing uh uh Bryce young because he's
one in eight and do they regret not
taking Cesar stoud the Panthers
absolutely not and this is why I hate
this because we love to just throw
people in the dirt when they're down let
Bryce young develop I think CJ stra may
have went into a little bit better
situation um there there there's not a
lot in Carolina right now you know you a
lot of people said about their offensive
creativity um I don't think they're
using to him strength Bryce young uh
their offens line hasn't been the best
uh you could say the running game hasn't
been the best uh the receivers hasn't
really been the best um so there's a lot
more at hand that Bryce has to deal with
so there there's that so I don't think
we should just throw away Bryce just yet
I think we should let him get a couple
GE give him that same Grace as we did
everybody else and what I always keep
saying um and and you know I think it's
truly not fair even guys like Trevor
Lawrence who struggled their first year
look how well he's doing um now that he
has Calvin reallyy uh Z Jones they went
uh they went had Evan Ingram he grew he
grew uh it just takes times you got to
build a team that that supports him and
around him um I think he's very good
you've seen in his tape he can make
those Elite passes he can do that but it
comes down to coaching it comes down to
Talent around give him time let him
break out I think Bryce young will have
his breakout year it's just not this
year it will be in the upcoming years
but he still be good and actually play
Bryce young this week I'm extremely
excited to play him I think he has a
chance to be a l aite QB at this level
just let him keep building it's going to
be a fun game um I'm going to go over
the game plan right after this and and
get straight into it um but like I said
we can't sleep on this team we have to
bury this team um and we have to keep
winning forward because we got a
extremely hard schedule it's November
December football uh y'all know what it
is it's importance everything about this
is importance um and and that's last but
not least I'm going see y'all there
Sunday let's take some final questions
from the chat yes I do believe
Washington will figure it out um you
know they have a great OC over there
that came from the Chiefs to help
Patrick mahom Sam how is going to
continue to get better they're going to
keep making picks they let go their
edges but they still have that Elite
wide receiver
Talent uh they still have you know uh
things around them the coaching is good
they're they're changing the culture
they're trying to change the culture so
I think Washington will figure it out
and we play them um you know on
Thanksgiving so it will be a fun game do
you care about your stat she if you guys
still get the W no always the win is
extremely important I think just a
competitive side you always want to do
better you always want to play your best
you always want to be elite and that's
just the reality of it has nothing to do
it's about your personal uh goals mixed
in with your team goals and things like
that yo M have you come up with a name
for your call Celebration not yet I'm
holding on to it but when I do it will
be funny it will be uh you know a little
crazy but I want it to be different I
want to be different uh out of the
ordinary outside the box um would you
rather see Philly for a third time or
San Fran for a second time in the
playoffs honestly it don't matter we
have a modelto in our room line up get
effed up and as simple as that uh when
it come playoff time it don't matter who
you face you might have to play them
anyway so ain't no avoiding you got to
take everything head on and that's just
reality of football and in
life I got so M I got barbecue sauce on
my uh Michael Parson's Jersey Sunday uh
Hey man we G have to get you a New
Jersey bro or cuz come on man and and
put down the barbecue sauce no eating
barbecue wings during game time and
always choose Buffalo always ch buffalo
buffalo is the best flavor uh can I get
a birthday shout out Micah uh Hey I want
to give a shout out to NJ Curtis X happy
birthday brother uh wish you all the
best uh love and more blessings forever
your Endeavor brother keep going keep
striving and keep achieving and always
trying a way to change someone's life
around you brother hey I appreciate
y'all for tuning in to the edge I'mma
see y'all next Monday love and
appreciate y'all forever man
[Music]
love